money is the equivalent of energy so you
can buy energy with your cash and the
significance about that is if you're
frugal and take care of your money and
keep a balance then you always have this
energy in your bank account energy in
which you can live
however obviously if you waste this
energy then you actually interfere with
your own survival so you don't really
want to go out and just throw away your
money and so basically i really want to
show you that this is an important
insight into the nature of our own
health and our biology in the world we
create in this regard that our
biological system the cells rely on
energy without energy there's no life so
fundamentally you have an energy budget
that gives you life and in fact in the
body energy is in coins called atp
molecules that represent units of energy
so in fact biologists refer to atp as
the coin of the realm the significance
of atp is this
is that atp molecules are like units of
gasoline like gallon of gas that are
used to fuel our biological processes so
to stay alive we have to have all this
atp so there's an atp account in your
body right now
but the question is how do you use this
atp and now here's an important fact
that
25 of the total energy in your whole
body is used to operate your brain so
all of a sudden you start to recognize
that the brain uses energy at the rate
of muscles of a marathon runner so a
brain and muscle activity are pretty
much the same and so why is this
important because as you're using your
brain as you're using your thinking you
are actually using energy now why is
this relevant the answer is very simply
this because the way we've been using
our thoughts are not necessarily
productive a matter of fact sometimes
our investments of our thoughts are
actually counterproductive because our
thoughts create a reality that we then
have to overcome so basically it says
that we must start to become aware of
our thoughts and why is this important
because thoughts represent units of
energy every time you have a thought you
use energy why this becomes relevant is
if i give you a checkbook for your bank
account you don't go down the street and
just write checks to people like oh hey
you're a nice looking guy here's 10
bucks for you and oh here little girl go
out and buy yourself a little car here's
a thousand dollars for you and you don't
give away your money why because giving
away your money is giving away your life
so basically you become very frugal when
you have a checkbook in your hand
now what i'm trying to tell you is this
you have an energy budget in your body
the energy is what keeps you alive when
you start using energy and writing
checks where you get no return from your
energy then it's exactly the same as
writing checks out of your bank
checkbook and giving away your cash so
why this becomes important is the
biology of belief
reveals how our thoughts create our
reality and if you start investing in
thoughts that are counterproductive
thoughts like fear or what am i going to
do and how am i going to escape this
problem or how is this going to go wrong
and all these other kinds of thoughts
that are negative kinds of thoughts then
realize this
you are actually not just using your
energy for having these thoughts but
these thoughts are also what come into
your reality what you focus on with your
thoughts your brain will manifest as
reality everything you do in your life
you put out energy for therefore start
to review what you're doing in your life
because if you're putting your energy
into things you cannot change in this
world that is exactly the same as
writing a check and just throwing away
your money to the outside because you
get nothing back from it so think about
this very interesting reality that you
have this energy checkbook and every
time you use energy you have to say is
the use of this energy
going to enhance my life or is it just
wasted energy am i getting involved in a
in a political argument with people
where i'm going to use up all my energy
and will i have changed the world no
am i going to use up all my energy to
try to convince other people to change
their life or change their way of living
to make them even healthier and they're
not ready to do that i'd be wasting my
energy
so here's an interesting thought
if i gave you an energy checkbook and
asked you to write a check every time
you had to have a thought you would have
to then ask yourself is is this thought
going to enhance my life or is this
thought going to take away from my life
and then when you start to realize that
you start to direct your actions where
you put your energy into things that
enhance your life and give you an
opportunity to survive and to go beyond
survival and really into thriving
so the point is this we are facing some
rough times the more thoughts you put
into the negative aspect the more
thought you put into the fear
not only are you just wasting your
energy but as in the biology belief
these negative thoughts these negative
stresses actually impair your immune
system and bring on disease itself
and in 1925
physicists said that our vision
of a universe split into an invisible
energy realm and a material physical
realm was a total illusion
that everything is energy the whole
thing there is no matter in this world
and to summarize what the meaning was a
famous physicist in 1930 by the name of
sir james jeans said we have been led to
believe that the universe is a great
machine
when in fact
it is more a great thought
and the reality about that was quantum
physicists have established since 1925
that consciousness is the primary
mechanism of creativity of the world
that we experience in fact a more recent
article in the journal nature which is
like a
scientific mainstream journal was an
article by a quantum physicist at johns
hopkins university by the name of
richard conhenry
and his article was entitled the mental
universe
i i know the last two lines in the
article because they were like
so powerful and here's what the
conclusion of the article was
the universe is immaterial
it's mental
and spiritual
live
and enjoy
and this is so exciting because science
is coming out saying it's mental and
spiritual it's like oh my god but that's
the quantum physics part and the reality
about why is that and so important as uh
sad vijay had just mentioned
it's our thoughts
that are manifesting this world now you
could say that's a spiritual thing and
now i say not only is it spiritual now
it is fundamental basic science of the
universe and it says then the thoughts
are creative well if the thoughts are
created then who is having the thought
and you start to realize i'm having the
thought well then the truth is simple as
richard cohn henry said
you are creating this world with your
mental activity and your spirituality
combined and then all of a sudden it
says well then if i'm creating the world
then my original belief that when things
didn't go right
i was a victim
the universe wasn't supporting me you
know it's like oh i try so hard and the
universe is not giving me things it
turns 180 degrees around
and it basically says this
we
are creating this world
and then i say your mind is creating
this world and then i give you the
science that says there are two minds
that are operating at the same time one
is called the conscious mind and one is
called the subconscious mind i say
what's the difference
the conscious mind is where you are as a
spirit an entity a unique identity you
are
in that conscious mind and perceiving
the world i say what about the
subconscious mind it's not a creative
mind the subconscious mind is habits
things that you've learned and you
experienced in your life and they become
habits so uh the subconscious mind is
not thinking creating a subconscious
mind push the button
play the behavior
so here's the point when we are in our
conscious mind we are connecting our
spirituality to the biology and the
physical planet that we're in and that
is a creative mind that's the one you
wake up in the morning and say oh i wish
i had this and i desire that and these
are the things i want and then you go
out and start the day and then guess
what
95
of the day
you are not operating from the conscious
mind science has recognized 95 percent
of the day because we are thinking 95
percent of the day our behavior is now
controlled by the subconscious mind
i go okay so what's the difference in
the final conclusion of this is
the conscious mind with your creativity
has your wishes and your desires
the subconscious mind was programmed by
other people
your mother your father your siblings
and your community so what is the
difference
you wake up with a wish and a desire of
what you want
and then the rest of the day
you play the programs that you got from
other people that don't answer your
wishes and don't support your desires
and all you see is the consequence of it
and go oh my god why is it not working
the answer is because you don't see
because remember the name is
subconscious
below conscious
so when that behavior is playing
psychologists will tell us
70 percent or more
of the programs in the subconscious
are disempowering
self-sabotaging
and limiting behaviors
so the simple reality is this we have
great wishes and desires and yet our
life is not controlled by that our life
is controlled by the programming and
that programming is the disempowering
program so all you see is the
consequence of the invisible
subconscious which will sabotage
all the desires and wishes you have
and then to conclude that
what if you just didn't
default to the subconscious what if you
just stayed in the conscious mind that's
called being mindful
and why is it relevant
because when you stay
conscious keep your mind present
you are the creator of your life and
when people are in mindfulness they
manifest their wishes their desires and
their happiness so for all of us it's
sort of a wake-up call you think you're
running your life with your wishes and
desires it's an illusion
you're really running your life with
your programs acquired from other people
when you're putting in a wish and a
desire put it in as if you already have
it
i am healthy
uh i am a good relationship person uh
you know i have a great job
what's that i say it's like i already
have it and yet most people don't have
it so they'll say i want a great job i
want a great relationship i want to be
healthy and i go make a recording of
those words we just said that i want to
be healthy today right now tuesday we're
going to make a recording i say now come
back in one year and let's push the
button on that recording and we come
back a year later and it says i want to
be healthy i go it's a whole year and
you still want to be healthy still don't
have it right
you're going to say i am healthy
all you're emphasizing i have a desire
to be healthy i want to be healthy i
have a desire to be healthy i go
you can have that desire the rest of
your life you're not going to get
healthy you want to be healthy say i am
healthy but then you look and say yeah
but in reality i'm sick and i go no no
the function of the mind is to take the
program and turn it into reality so if i
am sick but i put a program in i am
healthy the mind looks you know like
well wait a second the program is i am
healthy but the body is not healthy so
what's the function of the mind
create health in the body it doesn't
change the program
it changes the body and so the idea is
this every time we put a program in it
has to be as if you already have it in
spite of the fact you could be dying of
cancer i go i am healthy
it sounds kind of weird and i go don't
worry about it just put it on i am
healthy because once it is a program the
function of the mind is to manifest it
as reality
that's the part and so my little caveat
you brought it up i'm emphasizing it and
that was simply this
that whatever you're downloading you
have to say it as if you already have it
because if you put a future tense on it
i will i want i say
if you record that that means you will
always will you know want to have it you
know i will do this you won't get there
so i just wanted to bring that in
because if we're making a program then
you must make sure it says as if you
already have it in spite of the fact you
don't
you as an identity are in your conscious
mind you actually are in there that's
where your personal identity is
and we have a tendency to say if i talk
to myself
i'm going to give myself a good talking
to and i'm going to change that
subconscious i say to myself bruce don't
do that again do this don't do that
again and and then i say it's very
frustrating why
you can talk until you're blue in the
face
and nothing will change i say why and
the answer is and this is the most
important part
there is nobody in the subconscious
there's nothing there it's a machine
it's a record playback device so you can
talk to the machine as much as you want
if you don't know how to push the record
button nothing's going to happen so then
i say how do you change the program i
said how did you get the program
the first seven years your brain was in
theta hypnosis
so i say you want to change a program
every night when you go to bed just as
your mind disconnects just as you fall
into sleep
your brain is now operating in theta
so if you put earphones on your head
and you play a tape a program a cd
of what you want
as your
your conscious mind disconnected
your subconscious is downloading so you
just play that tape as you go to bed and
after a number of playings your
subconscious will learn the new program
without even your conscience being
involved that's number one
after age seven
how do we put a program in repetition
how did you do anything you repeated it
over and over again how long did it take
you to learn the alphabet how many times
did you have to go from a to zed before
you could remember the whole alphabet
when you drove a car you didn't know how
to drive a car until you did what you
practiced you repeated so if you want to
change a program
you put into your mind a repetition
and it's not
it recognize this what you want to
change doesn't exist so when you put in
the new program it'll sound strange so
let's say you are sick
you have a disease and i say what
program do i want i am healthy
i go it doesn't sound right i know i'm
sick i say i don't care there's a saying
in english
fake it until you make it
what that means is if you want to be
happy just keep in your mind i am happy
i smile even if you have to force a
smile i am happy i'm smiling i say
repeat this and repeat this and guess
what
after a short time it becomes a habit
and when you're in that habit you don't
even have to think i am happy the new
habit will keep you happy all the time
because that's the new program in
today's world
i love the phrase because it it's funny
but it's true
fake it until you make it
mean you want to be happy
but you have to habituate happy you have
to say every day no matter if you don't
if you're not happy i don't really care
you have to tell yourself
i am happy i am happy you have to repeat
it ah habituation repetition why
i'm consciously repeating it every day
and looking at my life my life really
sucks oh bruce i am happy i am i'm
saying that
i go well why are you saying it because
repetition
is how the subconscious mind learns i
say why is this relevant and here's the
fun part
because after i've repeated it a number
of times the subconscious says okay i'm
happy i've learned this i go why is it
relevant that 95 of the day
the subconscious function is to make
that program real if my program is i am
happy the function of the mind is to
make sure i'm happy
if the if the program says i'm going to
get cancer because i heard that from
somebody else
then the function of the mind is to make
sure i get cancer because that's the
belief i'm working with
and if if it says i am a victim and i
can't get out of this
then the function of the mind is yep
look you see you i'm showing you you're
a victim and you can't get out of it
because i'm running a show you're a
victim okay i have a spiritual part and
i have this physical part and i asked a
simple question i said
why have a body
why not just be the spirit
and then
this is when i found out i had jewish
comedian cells i go i
i asked a question of myself
why have a body why not just be a spirit
and 50 trillion cells in my body welled
up with an answer and i said answer what
was i said i asked a question the answer
came back in the form of a question
that's where the jewish comedian guy
came in again i asked why have both a
spirit in a body and the cells answered
with this
quote
bruce
if you're just a spirit
what does chocolate taste like
and all of a sudden i said oh my god
that was the most profound thing in the
entire world i said why
because this is like a virtual reality
suit
i can see with these eyes
i could smell i can taste i can hear
and i go so why is it relevant well as i
said the question came out if you're
spirit only and sad vijay and i are in
the spirit world and we're saying love
is such a beautiful thing it's the
harmony and the connection and
everything i said yeah but what does
love feel like you know
as a spirit how the heck do i know it's
i say oh you have to have the chemistry
of the body and a nervous system
that translates the chemistry into
sensation
sensation is not chemistry it's
electromagnetic vibration it's a
broadcast
and i say so why is it relevant so we
had one little part i go what
we think our thoughts are in our head
and so we put wires on our head called
the electroencephalograph and i can read
your brain activity i go yeah inside
your head you've got all this
consciousness going on and then i go you
know there's a new technology reads
brain activity as well it's not electro
encephalograph eeg
it's called magneto encephalograph m-e-g
and i go so what's the difference they
both read consciousness i go yeah what's
the difference magneto encephalograph
the probe is out here it doesn't even
touch your head
stop
i say why
you're reading my thoughts out here
and all of a sudden it's like
my thoughts are not contained in my head
no
they're broadcast back to the field
i go i can read your thoughts from out
here
so whatever you're thinking positive or
negative or i can do this i can't do
that i it's not staying in here it's
going out into the world in the universe
around us
and then i say so what's the relevance
there's something called resonance when
two things are in vibration if one
vibrates the other one will vibrate
okay and if they're not in harmony one
vibrates and the other doesn't do
anything so i say so what does it mean
oh my god this is so
changed life stuff i go
my thoughts are vibration that go out
into the energy field which is quantum
physics i go so what
i say
my thought will only
vibrate and resonate with something that
matches the thought
if i send out a thought of love
only
elements that are in love that vibrate
within love will respond to my thought
because our we're in harmony we're in
resonance
if i send out a thought of fear negative
and scare and i can't do this and i'm
afraid
i said what do you think is going to
vibrate i say love is not going to
vibrate
only things that you would be afraid of
things you would be you know have fear
over
they'll vibrate and i say so
put it all together
oh my god
we're creators
and we come in to this body to create
and that what we create and what we
experience is not kept in us
our mind translates it into
electromagnetic vibrations that go back
to the field
and that integrates with our spiritual
vibration because they're the two in
resonance i'm in resonant with the
spirit and the spirit is in resonance
with the body why we're using the same
vibration
so
our lives make a difference
that we live here and i say what first
of all we're creators we're very
powerful
i go until a creator is programmed not
to be powerful
and then that creator by programming
will say okay i'm not powerful and give
up our power
and we have been systematically
programmed to question who and what we
are
when the fact is we came here as
creators
i go why did we come here for the
creation and i go because we get a
feedback that goes back to the source
that says what do you want and you come
here and try and create it and when you
find that love and when you find that
harmony you start to realize you're
glowing when you're glowing your energy
vibration of love is going back to the
universe to to resonate with you and
make you a stronger love
vibration
this is a time in history where it's not
enough to know there's a time in history
to know how
and if you rewind the tape 10 years ago
you know information was the thing that
stimulated thought stimulated new ideas
and and as we learn new things we make
new connections in our brains so
as we begin to add new stitches into
that three-dimensional tapestry in our
mind
we're beginning to cause our mind to
function in new ways but the key then
is to apply it to personalize it to do
something with it in in 10 years ago
when i went got in front of an audience
and talked about the application it
nobody wanted to step outside that
philosophical theoretical intellectual
realm right because doing something
means you're going to have to change
something about yourself yeah you're
going to get uncomfortable right
and um
i think we're in an age of information
and in an age of information ignorance
is a choice and because of technology we
have access to so much content
and information creates awareness and
awareness is consciousness and you can't
have consciousness without energy there
they work together so there's an
energetic change i think that's taking
place in the world right now where
people are so informed
that old models old paradigms are
beginning to break down whether it's the
medical model or the religious model the
education model journalism
the economy you know
politics it's all beginning to
come to the surface because something
else has to come out and and i think
that one of the things that uh people
are realizing is that you don't have to
be a buddhist monk to do this or a nun
with 40 years of devotion you just got
to understand the formula and just like
any skill or anything you learn
you got to go from thinking to doing to
being you got to take knowledge you
create the experience and if you keep
doing it over and over again you start
getting a skill or you start getting
wise about how to do it and you you know
that you know how to do it if you're
sitting down and you start thinking
about
some
future worst case scenario that you're
conjuring up in your mind
and you begin to feel the emotion of
that event
your body doesn't know the difference
between the event that's taking place in
your world our world and what you're
creating by emotion or thought alone
so most people then
they're they're constantly reaffirming
their emotional states so when it comes
time
to give up that emotion
they can say i really want to do it but
really the body is stronger than the
mind because it's been conditioned that
way so
the servant now has become the master
and the person all of a sudden once they
step into that unknown they'd rather
feel guilt in suffering because at least
they can predict it being the unknown
is a scary place for most people because
the unknown is uncertain people say to
me well i can't predict my future
i'm in the unknown and i always say the
best way to predict your future is to
create it not from the known but from
the unknown what thoughts do you want to
fire and wire in your brain
what behaviors do you want to
demonstrate in one day the act of
rehearsing them mentally closing your
eyes and rehearsing the action
they're rehearsing the reaction of what
you want or
the action of what you want by closing
your eyes and mentally rehearsing some
action
if you're truly present the brain does
not know the difference between what
you're imaging and what you're
experiencing in 3d world
so then you begin to install the
neurological hardware in your brain to
look like the event that's already
occurred now your brain is no longer a
record of the past now it's a map to the
future and if you keep doing it priming
it that way
the hardware becomes a software program
and who knows you just may start acting
like a happy you know dr maxwell mulch
wrote a book back around 1960
it was called self-image psychology
psycho-cybernetics it's a phenomenal
book
he said it was the greatest discovery of
his generation
he was a cosmetic or a reconstructive
surgeon and he found he would do work on
people he might have
done a nose job or removed a terrible
scar
and he noticed that when he did that
there was a phenomenal change in their
personality
but he noticed with others he would make
a phenomenal physical change and there
was no change in their personality and
that led him to postulate that we have
two images we have the one that's coming
back from the mirror but we've got an
inner image and that inner self image is
literally controlling our life
you will find people that have a very
poor self-image or low self-esteem they
won't look you straight in the eye
they're afraid to shake hands with you
they're very shy and withdrawn they go
through life hiding from life
they don't like themselves
they don't know themselves
do you know when a person improves their
self-image they change their entire life
their income change their relationship
change their health changes
and you know how you do that
start studying you start to find out
more about you
there's something phenomenal about you
do you know when i began to study this
material
57 years ago
i had very poor self-image i had low
self-esteem
i took dumb jobs i never earned any
money i never had fun i had poor
relationships and as i started to study
start to study real solid information
everything in my life started to improve
i've got friends all over the world
today i earn millions of dollars
i'm in my 80s and i get as much energy
as a person in their 30s
you see when you start to understand
really who you are you're god's highest
form of creation there's things about
you that just about blow your mind as
you start to study and really understand
them you'll walk a little taller you'll
stand a little straighter and you know
something you'll enjoy a whole lot more
of life see this line
that's called the terror barrier yeah
jumping at you isn't it
and on the other side of the terror
barrier is something we call freedom
and you know
very few people get through that terror
barrier it's rather sad
freedom is available to everyone
there isn't anyone
that cannot live the way they want to
live
see
why don't they
why don't they
they don't know
and they don't even know they don't know
now i'm going to show you
why people experience buyer's remorse
when they buy something they really want
and then they back away
where they go to move and they don't
they go to change jobs they don't
they go to move to another city and they
don't why
fear
causes them to stay where they are
there's the individual the x represents
the unknown
factor the paradigm
now there's a power flowing into this
individual's mind and they can make
anything out of what they want remember
we said we have the ability to choose
what do they choose they choose thoughts
that are in harmony with the paradigm
now here's an important point
the paradigm controls the vibration of
this thing we call our body
our body is a molecular instrument
that's really what it is it's a mass of
molecules and a very high speed of
vibration
the vibration that the body's in on a
conscious level we call feeling
when a person says they feel this way or
they feel that way what they're really
doing is describing the vibration
they're in
now
they choose thoughts
that harmonize with the vibration
they're in so they feel comfortable they
may not like the results but they're
comfortable
now let's move ahead
let's take a look here those people are
getting x-type results and they don't
like it
do you know what the problem with them
they're in bondage these people are
locked up
you know
paradigm is like keeping a person in a
prison
only there's no locks on the door they
can open the prison and walk out into
freedom anytime they want and they don't
they keep getting the same results over
and over and over again they're in
bondage
now let's go ahead here's the same
person
x type conditioning x type vibration
the power is flowing into them
and for some strange reason from left
field boom in comes a y type idea what
is the y type idea the y type idea
represents anything that you might want
to do that you're not doing
it might be moved to another city change
jobs
sell the house buy the farm whatever it
may be
ask the little girl for the date
ask the guy to go to lunch
go make the sale
buy what you want
go where you want to go that's the why
idea
but as long as the y idea is just in the
conscious mind it's just going to be an
intellectual exercise it's never going
to happen
so how do we make it happen well
that's when
everything goes haywire here we are here
same person okay the power flows in
and what do they do they got the y type
idea
now for some strange reason they know
that they've got to get emotionally
involved that they're going to act on
that idea they don't understand what's
going to happen but clearly understand
this
your central nervous system is the most
complex electrical system in the
universe
the central nervous system
is mind-boggling it would make the
electrical system in a super computer
look like a toy now the second you take
the idea from your intellect and impress
it upon the subject of mind that's when
all hell breaks loose
because the body moves in to an extra xy
vibration it's not in the x vibration
not the one that we're comfortable with
may not like the results but we're
comfortable no on a conscious level
everything's going crazy on a conscious
level we experience doubt that doubt
turns into an emotion called fear and
that fear is expressed through the body
as anxiety
see that person is getting emotionally
involved to move ahead do you know what
happens they hit that terror barrier and
they bounce off it and right back into
bondage
and they're so relieved to get back
there
they're back where they're comfortable
they've canceled the sale
they've decided not to move
they're going to stay in the job that
they don't like
at least they're comfortable
now that's not a very good way to live
and you know something that's something
everybody experiences if they're going
to grow you're going to hit that terror
barrier
see the terror barrier is going beyond
where you're at going to a new level i'm
going to tell you something when i set a
goal
if if if it doesn't scare and excite me
at the same time i know i'm going in the
wrong direction
now i also understand
that my paradigm is going to try and get
me to bounce back to where i was it
doesn't want me to move ahead
i don't want to live there
i lived there for the first 26 years of
my life and for the last 50 i've had a
phenomenal life and it just keeps
getting better and i want you to do the
same thing understand what i've just
said i'm going to back this up
they got emotionally involved in the y
idea
that moved their body into a different
vibration on a conscious level they're
experiencing some crazy stuff they start
to doubt their ability will never be
able to pay for it they experience fear
the fear expresses itself as anxiety
and bang you bounce off that terror
barrier and you're right back
oh i might not be earning much here but
i know what it is
i
i would love to move there but i'm
comfortable here i think i'll just stay
here these people are acting like they
have a contract to live forever and they
don't do you know what to do say i'm
going to get rid of all that i
understand it's there but i don't want
any part of it and i'm going to go
crashing right through that terror
barrier
now does that get rid of the x energy no
its energy
is still there
you see but at least you're over into
freedom you made the move you did it and
if you continue to feed the right
information into your mind keep feeding
that y idea keep getting emotionally
involved in the y idea you're there
you're on the road
keep doing that you're going to find
that the paradigm is going to change and
it'll just all go away
and you know where you're living
in freedom you're living where you want
to live
buyer's remorse
is when you cancel the sale
buyer's remorse is when you stop just
before you buy what you really want
before you go for the thing that's going
to change your life and you know it
it's not moving to the other city it's
not starting the business of your dreams
it's not stepping out and betting on
yourself
that's a terror barrier that's causing
that
and if you don't learn to go through the
terror barrier i'm going to tell you
something you're going to stay right
where you are
for the rest of your days
that's not a good place to be
what did joseph campbell say
so true
they cave you fear to enter
holds the treasure you seek how many
times have you had somebody say to you
hey have you got a minute bomb
have you got a minute
they don't want a minute
i want you to think about that
i read a poem one time i said i have
only just a minute
only 60 seconds in it
it was forced upon me i can't refuse it
i didn't seek it and i didn't choose it
but it's up to me to use it
i must suffer if i lose it give a count
if i abuse it it's only a tiny little
minute but eternity is in it
well anyway i thought i'm going to put
this on a video and i'm just going to
share with everybody just this one
little part of the seminar i'm making
i want you to look at this sand timer
and let this i want you to think about
your life the sand in the top of the
glass represents the future the sand in
the bottom of the glass represents the
past
now do you know we know what's in the
past and yet we can't do anything about
it do you know what the trick is you
don't know how much sands in the top of
the glass you may think you have a lot
you might only have a little
then again you may think you have a
little and you might have a lot
when i was a little boy i was raised by
my grandmother and i don't know when i
was little gaffer she was probably 60
but
as long as i could remember grandma
would say and i'll soon be glenn dear
i'll soon be gone well you know we loved
her she was really an angel of god but
we thought she was never going to go she
lived to be 94 for 30 some years
i'll soon be gone
she didn't think she had much time left
she had 34 years left
now about the same time i had a buddy of
mine bob yates he was just 16.
and bang he run into the abutment of a
bridge and his life was snuffed out
if you had asked him a half hour before
how much sandy had left he would have
said at least a half a century he didn't
have a half an hour
see the trick is we don't know how much
sand we have left
the future
we don't know the past it's gone now the
only thing you can deal with is what's
right here right now and if you look the
sand is always moving
now think of this
you see i was working on that and then i
was working on a graph i've got here on
my computer
and i'm thinking of the time somebody
said have you got a minute
well they don't really want a minute
do you know if you're earning 50 000 a
year in minutes 42 cents
a half hour is 12.50
if we take that ahead of it if you're
earning eighty thousand dollars a year a
minute sixty seven cents
half hours twenty dollars
if you're earning a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars a year got a minute
it cost you a dollar twenty five a
minute
a half hour's 37 dollars and 50 cents so
if you see if somebody said you want to
stop for a cup of coffee
well
if you're earning a quarter of a million
dollars a year
a minute is two dollars and eight cents
half hours 62.50
and then of course you've got the coffee
to pay for on top of that
so you see
the point is this
this is all we've got right here right
now
we don't know how much we have left in
the future but we do know what we've got
now and i have found the people that win
are the people who make up their mind
they're not going to waste the minutes
they're going to be productive they're
going to make it happen
every minute you know the people you
surround yourself with have a phenomenal
impact on your life i think it was karl
menninger from the medicare foundation
one time said
environment is more important than
heredity
the people we're surrounded by have a
greater bearing on our life and our
success in life
than what's built into the genes at
birth there's genetic conditioning
there's environmental conditioning well
this environmental conditioning goes on
all the way through life
you will find as you improve the quality
of your life improve your thinking
you're going to attract a different
group of people into your life and they
are going to add to your life
[Music]
see the people we're surrounded by
their thinking is going right into our
mind
[Music]
we want to mix with people who are
really making it happen take a look at
your five people that you're with most
often
and ask yourself
if i have children would i want them to
grow up be like them if the answer is no
you better start looking for some new
friends if the answer is yes you're
already in the right circle of people
think about what i'm saying
the people we're surrounded with have a
phenomenal impact on our life and help
make us who we are select a person who
is already doing something that you'd
like to do get to know that person
go to the experts for advice don't ask
the person next door your mother father
or brother or the guy that works beside
you
because they don't necessarily know
there's no point in asking a person how
to earn a lot of money if they're only
earning 10 000 a year they don't know
they knew they'd probably be earning a
lot
it's like don't go to a sick doctor if
you want to get healthy okay so you find
someone that you can go to for advice
get a real good book and lock into that
book and start to study it like
i've had this one that looks like a
bible you know
but this is napoleon hill's book think
and grow rich i've been reading this
thing now for 23 years
i'll probably read it for another 23
years i get another good book that i
brought over here today it's called the
power of your subconscious mind
i'm not getting the commission for
selling this the author's
dead now he's been gone for a couple of
years but dr joseph murphy wrote this
book the power of your subconscious mind
and that's probably one of the best
books that you're ever going to find
because you're going to learn something
about your mind when you read this book
okay now i read a lot of books i've got
probably a thousand books sitting in my
den at home in my library but the one
that i care i carry it everywhere i go
and i read it all the time is think and
grow rich i never stop reading it
where's the value for you to reread that
and read it i mean you must
you must know it well enough that uh i
think i could probably recite it
verbatim but the secret is i once read
in the book where it said when you read
a good book through
the second time
you don't see something in it that you
didn't see before you see something in
yourself that wasn't there before you
see when i read this i created a greater
awareness william james from harvard
said believe and your belief will create
the fact
all things are possible if you believe
well you know i studied for a long time
i started to study this book think and
grow rich and he talks about belief in
here he says you're not ready for what
you want until you believe you can get
it
i found that the
only two sources of reference we could
go to to find out anything about
ourselves is science and religion
they all say you've got to believe
so i get figured out
how do you how do you believe
how do you change a belief
interesting subject because i'm going to
tell you something
your results are nothing but the
manifestation of your belief system
well our belief system of listening
carefully is based upon our evaluation
of something and frequently when we
re-evaluate a situation our belief about
that situation will change
let me repeat that
our belief system is based upon our
evaluation of something
frequently if we re-evaluate a situation
our belief about it will change
i began reevaluating who i was i started
to study i never stopped studying and i
found as i reevaluated i had a much
higher opinion of myself i found out
things about me that i would have never
believed if you had told me the power
that's locked up within us the marvelous
system we've got you know the blood
circulates through your veins every 33
seconds through hundreds of miles of
passageway bang just like that colors
all the food in and all the garbage out
stop and think of the central nervous
system it's the most complex electrical
system in the world
and you've got it
think of your brain an electronic
switching station like that you can
change the vibration of yourself and
everything around you
we have awesome powers and it's all
based on what you believe about you you
know many years ago i read a book by
terry cole whitaker it was a classic
what you think of me is none of my
business think of the amount of time
that is wasted on negative energy
wondering what other people think of you
what they think of you really doesn't
make any difference it's what you think
of you that makes a difference so as you
go through the day
don't
worry about what other people think of
you
just say
i'm all right i'm god's highest form of
creation he said that success was the
progressive realization of a worthy
ideal anyone that has a goal and they're
moving towards it they're successful
most people think that you're successful
if you have a lot of money quite often
you have a lot of money if you're
successful but it isn't i wouldn't say
mother teresa
has a lot of money okay but she's a
pretty successful lady
so it's um
okay so that barrier to these well
there's a couple of them okay i think
there's two barriers one is our
conditioning the conditioning that takes
place in our subconscious mind from the
time we're infants
all we can do is act and talk like the
people around us that's why we learn the
language we learned if there was 10
languages spoken in our home we'd learn
10 languages without any trouble
there's usually one and that's the only
one we ever learn and we grow older and
we think well i couldn't learn another
language we could learn a hundred if we
wanted to you can do anything but i
think we're conditioned we have a
real strong conditioning usually with
not some very good ideas
and then that that's the
the barrier that's inside is the one
that's outside of us says our
environment we have a tendency to act
like everybody around us
and if you think about this it doesn't
make a lot of sense because if you study
statistics 95 of the people live their
entire life and never live the way they
want to live
you know that 95 percent of the
population in this country let's say in
north america okay the richest continent
in the history of the world
they'll work productively let's say for
40 of their 65 years okay and they'll
end up with hardly any money
well there's got to be something wrong
so there's no five percent of the people
end up financially comfortable or
independent
are you trying to depress this bob
because that's uh no actually i think
it's i think it's quite an exciting idea
because you see the idea behind it is
that anybody can win
anyone at all
but if we start studying these
statistics i think we'll arrive at the
conclusion geez i better start thinking
for myself rather than follow everybody
most people they get a job they look
around they see how everybody else is
doing their work and they start doing it
the same way
they should stop and think i wonder if
any of these people know what they're
doing
is there a better way to do it but don't
we have a need to fit in i mean we don't
want it we don't want to stand out we
don't want to get fired we don't make
waves
exactly exactly just fall into line you
know take a number be like everybody
around
now that'd be great in the animal
kingdom
but human beings aren't supposed to live
that way i think we should make a few
waves
we should maybe stand out be different
not not for the sake of being different
okay but because we are different
we all think different thoughts
and i believe we should start to think
and build images in our mind of what
we'd like to do and then set out and do
it okay emerson did that edison did that
marconi did that and samuel morris did
that uh buck minister fuller did that we
could go on and on and on okay they were
different they stood out they made a few
waves i don't think you determine what
your purpose is i think you discover
what your purpose is there's a
difference determining
indicates deciding
um and i don't think you decide i think
if you go about it the right way you
discover it
like there's some people that should be
painting
all day they're great artists
i think michelangelo was obviously a
great artist great sculptor
i mean
that was his purpose
in his life
well
i believe my purpose
is doing what i'm doing your purpose is
why you get out of bed in the morning do
you know why you get up well most people
say well it's to go to work well that'd
be a good reason to stay in bed you know
you say well everybody's doing it that'd
be another reason to stay in bed if
you're ever doing what everybody's doing
you're probably going in the wrong
direction
your purpose is your reason for living
what you want to do is sit down
and maybe
take a pen
and a pad
and then ask yourself what do i really
love doing now you may have to spend a
while at this
you might get up an hour early every
morning
and
go sit under a tree somewhere if you're
in a nice climate
or pick a favorite chair someplace where
you're not going to be disturbed
and totally relax
and say
if i could spend my life doing something
what do i really love doing
now since you don't ask yourself that
question every day it might take a while
for this answer to come to the surface
but it comes to your consciousness
and it may take a while you may have to
do this every morning for
three months
but it would be
well invested you've got to wake up
you see
all we're ever going to get is awareness
we've already got everything
the only thing we lack is the awareness
of what we've got
we're god's highest form of creation
there's nothing on the planet that will
equal us
well
that's all we're that's all any of us
are after all the problems in the world
come from ignorance
that's the purpose of life overcome
ignorance
develop awareness the only way to
overcome their ignorance is through
knowledge and the only way to get the
knowledge is to study
most people they finish school close the
book saying that's over i'm never going
to open another book as long as i live
they're screwed it's all over because
you made it this far in a video i want
to celebrate you most people start and
don't finish most people never actually
follow through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you're special believe nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want some incredible motivation from
wayne dyer check the video right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there have a mind that is open to
everything
and attached to nothing
one of the central principles of my life
is that no one knows enough